[Music]
you were with them I was all I can say
is that when I left them you know on the
beach engaged they were seem to be very
much in love and actually the last time
I saw them together was on stage at the
special that we shot and you know if
she's faking it she fooled me too
it's and I haven't talked to either one
of them so I don't know the validity of
any of it I don't know what's happened
since today because it seems to be like
a very fluid situation but I hope it's
not true I truly do that would be a
pretty terrible thing to do
and cuz Jordans a good guy I know
Jordans very much in love with her but
then again I just I don't know I don't
know what I don't know we'll find out
that's luckily I have you guys to figure
all that stuff out from here I mean they
try and make it work and they are you
rooting for them I of course I'm rooting
for them yeah I mean I again its I it
all depends on if any of this stuff is
true I don't know and maybe hopefully
Jordan has more information than any of
us I think he's gone kind of radio
silent which I understand and hopefully
she has too and that's the thing they
can do is probably stay off a red carpet
unlike yours truly top ten dumb things
you could do tonight this is how
desperate I am to see Jerry Seinfeld
this is where you know honesty where the
job stops and taking care of human
beings begins and we do we rally the
troops and you know circle the wagons
and we're there for these people whether
it's Jenner whether it's Jordan both of
them because it's just as important that
Jenna's okay we're taking care of her as
it is Jordan and we'll make sure that
everybody's is well cared for as
possible and support them however we can
a lot of this stuff now is going to be
off-camera a lot of conversations will
take place you know and we won't be
shooting it this won't be for specials
it's just making sure that these human
beings are okay I know I hopefully I'll
have more you guys will probably have
much more in bubble 4 I will okay I like
I am you know speaking of this event
being a dad the dads always the last to
know
and I am typically the last person to
find out in this household what my kids
are up to
well how he's going to do and how is he
as a dancer are two very different
questions he's gonna do great because
it's a popularity contest people will
love him he's endearing so he's gonna do
good
he won't do good but I think that's
gonna be the beauty of Joe if he
embraces his suckiness its endearing
it'll be great because that's the whole
point of Dancing with the Stars is
taking a guy and putting him on the
dance floor that has no business being
on the dance floor that's the point of
the show it's that's that's what we love
about it so I wish him well I'll be
there front and center as much as I can
when I'm not helping Colton find love
and I think he's gonna do good he'll get
my vote every week